the non-dual approach as i said goes
much deeper it it first of all
investigates what we essentially are
and it it in this investigation we trace
back
our experience of ourselves discarding
everything that is
not essential to us our thoughts are
obviously not essential to us they are
always
appearing and disappearing our feelings
likewise sensations
perceptions activities relationships
these are all
elements of experience that are added to
us they remain for a while and then they
leave us but what is the us what is the
essential irreducible element
of our self and if we if we undergo
this experiment and it's a very simple
experiment anybody can do it
we end up with just our simple being our
simple
self-aware being it's like
it's like undressing at night when we
when we go to bed at night we
we take off all the layers of clothes
each layer is of course superfluous to
us the clothes are changing all the time
and we get to our naked bodies that that
element of our self relatively speaking
that cannot be removed that is our naked
being well
if we do the same thing relative to our
experience and we take off
so to speak our thoughts feelings
memories
sensations perceptions activities and
relationships we end up with
pure awareness and this is a pure
self-aware being
so this is the first great discovery
and that's what we share is that well
i was just going to say that the first
step
is the discovery i am awareness
this is not yet what is referred to as
enlightenment or awakening
in the traditions then the next step is
to investigate the nature
of everything so to review so we took
off all of the layers of identity
and then we got to the most primal
the most first principle which was the
awareness yes we took off everything
that we were
identified with everything that we
thought was
essential to us thoughts feelings etc
and we got back to our our naked
identity our original
our original face as they say in the the
uh
the zen tradition uh the the essential
nature of the mind as they say
in in buddhism the self as they say in
the
in the hindu tradition so that's the
first discovery
i what i essentially am is simply the
fact of
being aware or awareness itself the next
discovery is is to discover the nature
of the awareness that i am the the
discovery that it is ever present
that it has no limits and that its
nature is
it is inherently peaceful and
unconditionally
fulfilled and that this is the
recognition that is traditionally
referred to
as enlightenment so i would say this was
the second recognition
happiness is my nature the third great
recognition
meditation is not something that we do
it's what we are
we are the happiness the bliss the
infinity yeah yes the essential nature
of the awareness that i am is peace
or happiness yes okay and then the third
we can come back and just yes
the third great recognition which you uh
um
hinted at the the recognition that the
being
that we essentially are is shared
by not only everyone but everything
in other words everyone and everything
derive
their apparently independent existence
from a single infinite and indivisible
reality or whole whose nature
is well ultimately it is unnameable
because all names have evolved
to describe the content of experience
but if we are going to speak about these
matters
let's give it a provisional name in in
these circles we tend to speak of it as
consciousness or awareness in religious
circles it is referred to as
god's presence or brahman but in common
parlance
it is referred to as i myself my being
the the one infinite and indivisible
reality
which doesn't connect
us all because in the ultimate analysis
there is no all there is not
a multiplicity and diversity of objects
and selves each with their own
independent
existence to be connected in the
ultimate analysis
there are no independently existing
objects or self there is simply a single
infinite
indivisible whole which is refracted
through the prism of the finite mind and
appears as
many things and many people
so as a concession to the belief
that there are many things and many
people we can say that
we all share our reality but in the ul
if we really want to be try to be more
accurate in the ultimate reality
that there is no we there are no
objects ourselves either to be united or
not to be united there is
simply the unity of being that appears
as this multiplicity and diversity and
and the recognition
we are speaking of this in in
intellectual
terms and analyzing it with the use of
our rational mind
but the recognition that we share our
being
is a familiar recognition that millions
of people i i would suggest that
everybody has
some taste of and that is the experience
of love
love is the recognition that we share
our being yeah